you
hi everyone it's Jerry amount is calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game let's try
caro-kann all right advanced variation
okay happy so far they should
accomplished with my bad bishop
it's a little bit awkward to complete
queenside deployment because of the
control over f6
I guess they're shooting for a quick
Bishop 8 3
let's break
it was a really fast move I thought they
had another reasonable option of Bishop
8 3 or even c4 straightaway
for now
you have to take here first
possibility though at the end if the
Queen recaptures I have this so it's
opening up quite a bit
I think I have to get rid of this guy I
don't want to see this I need to make
sure that c5 opens up have anything
better probably not and I probably have
to take on d4 if Knight takes because of
this punch at f6
yeah if I do something like this there's
probably a sacrifice
I wonder if I'm able to even complete
development here come to think of it
uhh
because this is hitting really really
really fast
huh
well let's let's start with this
actually my mistake my mistake I could
play Bishop c5 with tempo and then get
get castled so I think I'm I think I'm
okay I think the worst is past
let's get castles and do I have anything
better I don't think so
Queen on e7 I think she could rely upon
that home I'd like to have the Knights
exchanged
my nights kind of stupid so let's give
him here with a punch
maybe get a dark square bishop exchange
um I know this is my better Bishop but I
think with more exchanges this will turn
to turn out to be a liability if I could
get one more pair of minor pieces
exchanged like this happy to see that
move
I proud
you just take
I know I'm inviting that rook forward
but
just going to have to deal with that and
contest this only open file well there's
two open files and we still need flight
squares each of us
do I have anything veteran I'm
considering yeah let's take I was
considering taking the night and then
dropping here I'd like it I like these
two to the exchange they're playing very
very very fast
all right let's still go with this Queen
takes I could box the night out for when
he arrives on e4 and then play my night
into d7 so there's a mini battle going
on over the d5 square
okay the
like my rook and then take on b7 I think
although
or even now now this isn't an idea just
yet try to take advantage of my back
rank can I get him Bishop to b4
rook Bishop d4
two extra queen takes or up Queen takes
pawn I take the knight and then go in
for a back ranker and the other
variation to consider I don't think so
I'm going to go with this now what am I
talking about they take my rook on and
take my bishop no thanks
alright let's go at this I'm still
hoping one day for a good night versus
bad bishop situation so maybe now I play
this move yeah right now I do this
yes and then I'm going to superglue my
knight on d5
ketchup
my eyes
I've consolidated I think let's get a
flight square or not just yet let's get
to this open file
that's not going anywhere
even if the Knights are exchanged I have
an instance of good versus bad bishop
clean here
to get in here
okay let's try to have any for
think so let's just stick around right
here as mentioned my bishop controls
their night so clean here is the only
thing I can maybe just go to see a to
stop clean the e8 maybe clean c6 instead
of producing a flight square first yeah
I'm going to no I don't want to see
Knight g5 and then converging on this
square I don't want to have to do this
and we can create a hole on f6 so this
is pretty standard now I'm opposite
their King and I stop going to be five I
have I have control over this Spokane I
really convert it computer probably say
equal giving some weight to this but I
would
prefer to play as black here 125 I guess
they're preparing a clean exchange like
this and then if I take they have split
pawns with my knight has to find a new
home
wonder if I could inch my king over here
yeah that's what they're gunning for
I'm going to decline a still keep the
cleans around I think this King is maybe
something I could take advantage of
still so let's say you have to be on the
lookout for this kind of capture in the
diagonal opening up like this move
combined with this I won't be able to
take twice on the d6 we'll see
popping up on right what's wrong with
sniffing this guy they gave me a pond
there all right I guess I have to take
care now I'm okay with an exchange
Queens
maybe my night could be in a better spot
let's try this endgame
my pawns are split but
up on
can I hang on to them though now maybe I
can't
clean 2d6
arrive there but don't I have some
checks right around this point shouldn't
they be a little bit scared of me
attacking pressure on the night this is
a threat to pick up the night they have
a check I just go here I only have 42
seconds though I've always start with
this and the queen isn't unprotected I
was thinking you have something like
that but maybe I'm setting it up now I
have to be on the lookout because they
have this kind of stuff with Knight to
f8 is 90 ec3 a threat though um let's
repeat for a moment I might have to just
take the draw
yeah I don't like to do this but I'm
gonna have to go for repetition here
I've wasted a bit too much time are they
going to maybe go for more I'm going to
take the draw here
um
yeah I'm not going to risk it with just
16 seconds there's still a lot more to
work work out here hmm I was thinking of
doing this but at the same time whites
whites counterplay is coming pretty fast
if I don't go for this repetition I know
I'm up upon but it's oh it's a long way
off before these guys get rolling and we
know how dangerous a queen and Knight
combo can be so if I try to do the
intended move like this - I don't know
try to infiltrate like this making use
of e - there's check this and there's
already at least a perpetual check idea
that white has maybe that have even more
but this would be a perpetual check idea
hmm
I like how I played the opening of
course it took a good chunk of time to
get the position that I did but let's
see what you really add you know things
got pretty sharp here with this c4 idea
you know and I think I was just in time
to get development and I don't know why
I was blind to Bishop c5 and being able
to cast like I was in trouble right
around here
I didn't voice it but I was thinking
about a sixth stop Bishop see Bishop to
b5 but they give they give to me upon
and I wonder right around here if I
could have maybe converted this better
they gave me upon but could I have a
force this kind of exchange somehow
nearly blundered at this point with
Bishop here yeah at this point Bishop
here would be losing because of that
spent a good chunk of time on that
position but uh yeah I don't know how I
could have maybe done better especially
if they didn't give me a pond
hmm it was tough
there's a little battle over the d5
square but I couldn't quite pull off
some Bishop for a night exchange and
then obtain a good night versus Bishop
but we'll see if the computer says
otherwise okay this is where I want to
be
with the engine on board so advanced
caro-kann calling this the short
variation okay so yeah just getting in
these standard moves denotes this from
the advanced variation an emphasis on
kingside deployment in other words
eventually my king Knight is pretending
to be a queen night arriving on c6 in
this game so is it okay to do this c5
move it's okay with it I felt like this
was maybe a little bit off to play
Bishop to b2 right around this point I
felt comfortable and I think I'm I have
officially equalized right around this
stage
computer agrees suggesting c4
that didn't Oh
it's White's move back to basics okay
yeah I was wondering why would see four
be good huh okay yeah white please see
four here and things get pretty opened
shop yeah so he turns out not to be such
a great piece did I respond properly
here I thought you have to take care
first because this would be too damaging
if this.c pun can make my kingside
structure flinch are really the e-pawn
flinch then then well how to say this
exactly if the C pawn is exchanged for
my e pond and there epon as a result
becomes mobile that's a problem I don't
want to give this pond the possibility
to move so let's take him out sometimes
you could see this reaction but it's not
it's not working in this specific case
because while I thought at least there's
Bishop to e6 but another suggestion is
to offer a queen exchange and actually
that would force a queen exchange which
is nice
okay so they don't have time for this
the bishop that's best especially since
I could take your next taking with a
pond there'd be a wounded duck here and
see for isolated ponds on the Queen side
so peace recapture is called for Bishop
takes c4 it is and it's just an equal
position and I'm pretty sure I've to
take on d4 because I don't want to see
this advanced computer suggest did Papa
Bishop e7 but now wants to take I did
chop-chop-chop Queen takes and Bishop c5
we just have an equal position so how
could I maybe played the middle game a
little bit better
Queen f4 is good
he's a really good defender for my
kingside but right around this point I
didn't feel as though there would be any
attack against my king
just gone with castles pretty normal so
too is Knight c3 is it like this
maneuver I don't see any other way to
really go with my knight and this is a
this is a whole white can't control d5
anymore so and I am getting to b6 with
tempo so it does like Knight b6
the insert that rook movers Queenie
seven that wants to go with I see that
right Knight to d5
tough to gauge ooh bishop d5 computer
esque
yeah pressure on that f5 I'm taking like
this okay well the more human like move
on board Bishop d3 that's a welcome
exchange I know I'm helping out the rook
just a hair but at this point I don't
see there being enough of a lead like
enough of a mobilization of whites
forces where you know that would be an
issue me me helping the rook improve
just a little bit and druk there were
there any tactics missed I don't think
so
one rook is off I could just get on with
getting my last piece working
right around here can I do something
different
wants to hold ground on the D file I
just took right
step up and then maybe Queen to d8 and
control this file
oh here you know here's another train of
thought I could have had right around
this point by taking here the Queen
probably prefers to be on d3 than e4
because it opens up the e4 square for
the knight and this is definitely where
he wants to be there's just not a better
Square for him so I guess a hair of an
improvement is rook to d7 but it still
should just be completely equal right
around here
what more I went h6 Bishop to b4 it is
like Bishop to b4 I really want to get
that exchange in but they were having
none of it
okay it does like Bishop to b4 and they
did a good job of ducking here 94 this
is what I want I want something like
this
good night versus Bishop it'll still say
it's roughly equal but there's really no
way that black is losing this cannot get
rid of this Knight and yeah he ties it
much better with the Queen and he's just
as a staring at his own pond so no this
isn't there there really isn't a good a
productive diagonal for the bishop if I
I was able to get this exchange in there
Bishop is just bad so 94 95
it's just equal yeah that's a good
flight square it also observes the F for
square takes away one of the jumping
points so that's uh that's the correct
one to go forward with most common is
are these moves but in this specific
case I like the G three advance
light-square weaknesses it's not like I
have a light squared bishop that could
take advantage of that okay so clean c7
oh they oh they had Knight to g5 right
here since I pulled my queen away from
watching over g5 okay it's still going
to say it's equal but I as mentioned the
game I wanted to avoid playing g6 and
creating a gap on f6 so I should have
been a bit more cautious and went with a
flight square here and only then when
elsewhere with my queen so fly square
would have been better here and they
didn't play Knight to g5 my bishop has
to relocate and now I went in for H six
it's just equal so what about the
position this final position where I'm
up upon they gave me a pun soon what's
that oh man
there's a tactic
it didn't even cross my mind Bishop
takes h4 context I have night f4
why didn't I say to myself that the the
King is now within checking distances by
night maybe had I said that to myself
that would have made me look a little
bit more into this tactic so there
wasn't an opportunity to pick off this
guy huh okay I went with queen c6
interesting king of three
right around this point when they seems
like that I'm expecting white to soon
follow up with the clean exchanges
otherwise he's kind of a bit too crazy
to enter the center of the board if the
Queen's are on the board
usually it would wait for the Queen's to
be off and then approach with the king
but he's just kind of inching up a
little by little d5 now it stops us
Queen c4 move hmm with a six
and now Queen c4 I backed off
and then
what kind of advantage does it give me
here yeah it is a troop on advantage
Bishop takes 83 so
I really don't know this is a tough
position I don't see how to move forward
I don't gain anything by moving indeed
my kingside pawns I really can't do
anything with my bishop we're kind of at
a standstill Bishop negates the knight
my knight is pretty much under
controlled by their pawns and their
Bishop and pawn over here their queen is
taking up an active post so tough to see
how to make forward progress
but after this move I pick up upon and
how could I maybe converted this with
what little time I had they want to
avoid the dark square bishop exchange
Bishop to be to instead okay I just went
in for the trade clean takes and they
could probably hunt down my pawn here
you know you see my night is just way
off and hunting him down and then I
guess I have to just go here to defend
and their King is pretty fast maybe he
would end up being lost yeah this pawn
over here and the knight control my king
pretty good this space advantages really
felt in an endgame normally this is a
great positive in the middle game
position where there's still a lot of
pieces on board but even in the
simplified position Knight endgame it's
tricky to work around the e5 pawn does a
good job
okay well Queens remain on board they
did have an opportunity to take them off
and split my structure now Queen c2 so
this is winning for me Knight there and
then what could I do to win king h7 hmm
that about just anticipating these these
checks who about the move I played check
it's another winning idea and not so
much huh
okay so here in now what is it
suggesting suppose they just go pawn
hunting pick up a pawn and put the night
on a terrible square would be the
winning idea here I'm picking up the
pawn and then the knight okay so what
about a check let's not check anymore
but suppose they go in for this idea
what am I doing here
I'm winning the night okay King h7 is
that's something I could have come up
with in game maybe I am controlling this
diagonal my king is a little bit safer
on h7 then g8 less accessible let's say
two checks okay for some for some reason
I was thinking I was able to do some
fancy Knight move and pick up the Queen
but she's protected
okay so King h7 would have been better
than this check
let me look one more that one more thing
suppose white does
I don't know I move like Queen
it's tough to even suggest something she
can't go too far because of this
pressure suppose the King just runs away
here to have a night reposition now
let's go with b6l removing the night and
then doing what making these of this
squared now Queenie to hitting the night
and then looking for this so if he tries
to get back in the ballgame
I don't know like this I have night to
e3 and it is a million three
so that's why they were playing King to
g1 anticipating my night to III move
King here we have a million two
very strong combo of pieces and here
it's just basically made on G to
wherever the King goes huh
yeah so that was the idea try and get my
night on III but I had to be a bit more
delicate make a move like King age 7 and
then try to uncoordinated tough to pull
off with a little time was remaining in
this one but in the final position where
do we stand after king DG 1 is that good
it's a fan of King to g1 and this is
where we just had repetition yeah I mean
I'm up that pond but it's it's not even
a full pond here as you're saying and I
think that was the best thing that I
could have done in this situation how
low on time I was but I don't like doing
that I usually avoid these uh
draws games ending ready to draw by
repetition if at all possible but I
think it was the right decision at this
point for this game okay well as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below and I
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye
you